comme on pouvait s'y attendre les
sanctions adoptée par bruxelles et
washington dans le cadre de la sphère
navalni ont été fermement dénoncée par
le kremlin qui y voit une ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures du pays les
autorités qui juge scandaleuses les
accusations qui tiennent le fsb pour
responsables de l'empoisonnement supposé
de l'opposant russe
elles ont d'ailleurs promis de répondre
à ces sanctions en temps et en heure
évidemment ces sanctions ne resteront
pas sans réponse c'est évident la
réponse correspondra de la meilleure
façon à nos propres intérêts nous allons
convenir de sanctions présenter nos
propositions à la direction pour
signature
et une fois approuvées elles seront
annoncées nous en informerons ensuite
nos adversaires mais à entendre le porte
parole du kremlin il s'agit au final
d'un non événement en effet les
personnes ciblées par les sanctions sont
des haut fonctionnaires qui de toute
façon n'ont que peu ou pas de contacts
avec des pays tiers
ces gens là ne vont de toute façon pas à
l'étranger nous n'ont pas le droit
d'ouvrir les comptes dans les banques
étrangères d'avoir des biens à
l'étranger et cetera cela n'est pas
appliqué un certain nombre de personnes
morales et qui figure également
mais ce n'est pas ce qui compte nous
estimons que toute restriction de ce
type est tout à fait inadmissible parce
qu'elle lui sensiblement aux relations
qui sont déjà dans un état déplorable
en l'occurrence les relations avec les
états unis et avec l'union européenne
ce n'est qu'une ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures de la russie ce
n'est pas à nous d'expliquer leur
motivation que ce soit des restrictions
ponctuelle ou pas de manière générale
nous estimons que les décisions de ce
type sont absurdes et dépourvue de
fondement
et ce qui est le plus important elles
n'ont ni effet me sens à cet égard nous
ne pouvons qu'exprimer notre regret
notre perplexité
même si au final ces sanctions revêtent
avant tout un caractère symbolique
elles ne font que dégrader des relations
déjà au plus bas entre moscou et les
capitales occidentales
ailleurs dans le monde on a également
réagi à ces annonces et sans surprise
londres a accueilli positivement ces
nouvelles sanctions tandis que la chine
a dénoncé ce qu'elle considère être une
ingérence dans d affaire strictement
interne à la rue